remember i said square is not the exact
opposite of taking square root
okay they're not exact opposites to each
other
so what should i do here
what should i do
any suggestions remember what i'm after
is i want to get the cube by itself
i want to undo this okay what would be
the opposite of taking the square root
well the closest the closest thing we
know is squaring right
let's try that let's try it if i square
this side
i should square this side
yeah is that okay what am i going to get
on the left hand side
that's just going to be q isn't it right
yeah that's okay what's 2.5 squared
that's an awkward number
it's it's 6.25 um if you if you
don't recognize that number it's okay
your calculator can't help you there but
you could you could just multiply it out
with like
place notation now here's my question to
you
you know how here and here we added a
plus or minus
and we said look look there are two
solutions right should i have a plus or
minus here
does anyone think we should why not
yes yes no why or why not
because i added it i added it here
should i add it here or should i not
this is this is a confusing point
um now because it is pretty hard i i
will tell you the answer
the answer is don't add a plus or minus
okay now let's think about this so what
anna's talking about
is if i take a negative number right
suppose suppose i had thought i do want
a plus minus
i want negative 6.25 as well remember i
keep on saying the way to know whether
you got the right answer or not
is take the key and stick it in the lock
and does it work
okay so if you go up here and you say
okay i'm going to take my negative 6.25
and i'm going to stick it up into this
first line
square root of negative 6.25
okay so you look at this and you're like
hmm i don't know what that is
i'll go to my trusty calculator right
and you type in the numbers you
square it simple okay you put your
numbers in now
what happens when you press equals
syntax no seriously what happens when
you put in the numbers you get an answer
what do you get
i i get i get math error
we broke the universe everyone okay
okay which by the way uh is a similar
thing to what happens when you go
and divide by zero if you take a number
like one and you try and divide it by
zero put it into your calculator
and again you get math error what does
that mean
something's wrong you say you're fired
calculator can't believe i spent 25
bucks on you
uh you can't even give me the answer
it's not that hard a question
what does it mean the answer is well the
meaning the meaning behind math error
right is that this number yeah well
at least in the numbers we're interested
in it doesn't have a meaning here's what
i mean okay
what i mean uh square root of right
the square root of say 25 okay it's the
number that if i multiply it by itself
you get 25 and that's why you told me 5.
because if i multiply 5 by 12 you'll get
25 cool
so this this is asking the question
what's the number that if i multiply it
by itself
i'll get negative 6.25
and the answer is at least in the
numbers that you're familiar with
there isn't a number that you can
multiply to make it a negative
because we saw before right you do
positive times a positive
and you'll get positive right if you do
negative
times a negative guess what tough you
still get a positive
right so there's no numbers in this
family of numbers
that can satisfy this okay it hasn't got
a solution
um that in numbers that we're familiar
with okay now
here's the thing not that you need to
worry about it but there is a family of
numbers that was invented
um to come up with answers to this um
they're called
i kid you not this is their name they're
called imaginary numbers um
i would write it like this 2.5
i for imaginary right you're like really
really is that a joke no it's not it's
not a joke
um it's something which if you're
curious about you can ask me about later
but here's the important thing okay
these numbers right you're used to
dealing with these okay
but i don't know if you remember like
way way way back early like in year two
or year three okay i might have posed
this question to you
i might have said okay i've got i've got
i've got four markers okay i've got four
markers how do i
share this among four people how many
markers would everyone get and you would
answer as a beautiful year two students
one marker each because i can't just
conjure up markers
four people four markers i'll give you
one each no problem
and then i would say again okay what if
i've just got two people
and four markers okay how many markers
does each person get and you take two
okay then primary school teacher says
all right now i've got four markers
what if i want to split them on three
people and then and then you guys you
you two
say you're fired you know you can't
divide four markers into three people
one person will get one another person
will get one and then you've got these
two markers and everyone's gonna hate
that guy because he's got two
people like as everyone else your
sister's favorite because you can't
divide them up right
now here's the thing you well you could
break them in first but then you don't
really have
like if i break this up in three you've
got no markers there
right so so then you can't divide four
into three
but you guys you guys are advanced and
you're seven you learn about fractions
you're like aha
there is a number you all get four
thirds of a marker and then you two
students kind of go
you know that's not a number you can't
have four thirds of a marker
my point is right you were all telling
me
you were telling me equate solutions to
this right
divide it into four or divide it into
two and then i gave you divide it into
three and you're like nah doesn't work
well it does work we had to invent a
whole new kind of number
to deal with that they're called
fractions right and that's what this is
about
so you won't ever have to solve these in
your ten anyway okay
but these numbers exist